thank you very much indeed Hannah and
thank you to everyone here this evening
it's a great pleasure to host this event
on behalf of intelligence squared and
it's a huge pleasure to introduce Thomas
L Friedman possibly the world's most
famous journalist although Clark Kent
might take it that he's the lead foreign
affairs columnist for The New York Times
and he's won the Pulitzer Prize three
times he's the author of several books
the most recent those being thank you
for being late an optimist guide to
thriving in the age of accelerations
which was published just a couple of
years ago and he's well known for filing
reports from the farthest ends of the
earth although I didn't if you'd made
out of space yet and so maybe that's the
next two to come so it's pretty amazing
that they managed to actually tie him
down in London for just a couple of
hours today Tom a pleasure to talk to
you I have to say that you have little
competition this evening because to be
here I'm having to miss the
international evening of my daughter's
grade school and they promised
Macedonian folk dancing so your your
international evening is gonna have to
measure up pretty high to compete with
that I have work before we start our
conversation there Tom I think you
perhaps might want to just lay out the
ground for us for a few minutes and tell
us how the world looks now as you see it
in 2019 well first around thank you for
doing this and thank intelligence
squared for hosting me and thank you all
for coming out this is just it's
wonderful I think to understand
everything I'm going to talk about
tonight um you have to understand how I
approach writing a column and my motto
which I learned from my teacher Lynne
Wells who teaches at the Defense
University in Washington is never
thinking in the box never think out of
the box
today you have to think without a box
and what I'm going to share with you is
basically everything I talked about
tonight will be under that framework so
my last book thank you for being late is
really about underneath its kind of how
I organize a column and to write a
column in The New York Times basically I
think you have to combine three
chemicals a new story is meant to in
and I could write a new story about this
event tonight and Rhonda would tell me
where they're informed better or worse
but a column what I do
piñon these is actually meant to provoke
it's actually meant to producer reaction
so I'm either in the heating business or
the lighting business that's basically
what I do I mean they're doing a heating
or a lighting I'm either stoking up in a
motion in you arm illuminating something
for you and if I really do it well III
do both and I know I've succeeded if you
read over my columns and you say um I
didn't know that that's good I provided
some light I never looked at it that way
that's good more light um I never
connected those things more like your
favorite is a column did you kind of
live for this happens three times a year
when people say I read your column and
mr. freedom you said exactly what I felt
but didn't know how to say I got god
bless you god bless you
and then there's I want to kill you dead
you and all your offspring
that's when I create a little heat and
um but I explained to people that to
create heat and light requires a
chemical reaction you have to actually
combine three chemicals a one is your
value set what what are the values
you're pushing out in the world are you
a communist a capitalist and the economy
or liberal or libertarian or Marxist the
Keynesian what values are really
animates you um second and this will be
the thrust of what I talk about is how
do you think the machine works so the
machine is my shorthand for what are the
biggest forces shaping more things in
more places in more ways on more days
and as a columnist I'm always working on
that that's my books are about I'm
always trying to update how do I think
the machine works today because what I'm
trying to do as a columnist is take my
values and push that machine in their
direction and if I don't know how it
works a there won't push it or I'll push
it in the wrong direction lastly what
have you learned about people in culture
because there's no column without people
there no people without culture how does
the machines movement affect different
people and how does their movement
affect the Machine stir those together
let it rise bake for 45 minutes and if
you do it right you two can be columnist
in the New York Times so so what I want
to share with you just for starters Ron
is is how I think the machine works
today and I think what is shaping more
things in more places in more ways on
more days
is that we are in the middle of three
nonlinear accelerations all at the same
time with the three largest forces on
the planet which I call the market
mother nature and Moore's law so if they
just queue up the PowerPoint for one
second get that going and so if you put
mother nature on a on a graph or and
mother nature for me as climate change
biodiversity loss and population growth
in the developing world so if you put
mother nature on a graph or at a picture
it looks like this is Glacier National
Park in America 1913 and Glacier
National Park 2012 that glacier was
there for 7,000 years that's Lake Chad
up there the big blue thing in 1963 and
that's Lake Chad 2013 put Mother Nature
on a graph she looks like a graph of
global average temperature she looks
like a big hockey stick put mother
nature on a graph she looks like a graph
of extreme weather another hockey stick
or put mother nature on a graph the
mother of all hockey sticks world
population growth through history so if
you put mother nature on a graph today
she is one big accelerating hockey stick
now the market for me is globalization
but not your grandfather's globalization
that was containers on ships and planes
that's actually pretty flat today what's
globalizing the world and knitting it
together day it's actually digital
globalization though everything's being
digitized and globalized through through
online courses through PayPal through
Facebook through Twitter etc put
globalization on a graph today it looks
like another hockey stick total data
consume per month or it looks like
another hockey stick mobile cellular
subscriptions in the United States in
the UK in France in Gabon the graph all
looks the same another hockey stick and
lastly what globalization on the graph
it looks like global Internet users
another hockey stick the last
acceleration is in Moore's law so
Moore's law was coined in 1965 by Gordon
Moore the co-founder of Intel who
posited in a famous article in
electronics magazine that the speed and
power of microchips will double every 24
months and the price would stay roughly
the same Moore's law has held up for 54
years and if you put it on the ground
it looks like the mother of all hockey
sticks the power of microchips just
doubling doubling and doubling this
power points running on a laptop back
there
it actually has I'm pretty sure an Intel
14 nanometer chip in it um it has 35
million transistors per square
millimeter last January until began
shipping it's 10 nanometer chip it has a
hundred million transistors per square
millimeter what's the difference between
35 million and a hundred million is the
difference between a self-driving car
that needs just a little but that needs
the whole trunk of the car to contain
the brains of the car and a self-driving
car that needs a little box under the
front seat now um 19 a few years ago
Intel decided to explain the power of
this Moore's law acceleration they got
their engineers to try to figure out
what would have happened if you took a
1971 Volkswagen Beetle and it had
improved at the same rate as microchips
had since 1971 and they estimated that
if that had happened that VW beetle
today would go 300 thousand miles an
hour it would get 2 million miles per
gallon and it would cost you four cents
you'd be able to drive it your entire
life on a single tank of gas that is the
power of the technological exponential
driving our lives and the flow rate down
and reboot every 10 minutes that's
probably true but to tie it up
Ronna that I think that we're in the
middle of three giant hockey-stick
accelerations in the market mother
nature and Moore's law and they're not
just changing your world they're
reshaping your world and they're
reshaping five realms in particular and
that's what thank you for being late is
about there reshaping politics
geopolitics the workplace ethics and
community thank you very much for the
really very broad and very wide over
sides of these various factors
interacting with each other and let's
get straight to the analysis of some of
these factors now one of the things that
you've written about but I think really
bears some examination is the confluence
of two particular dates they're
historical dates but not very far in
history 2007-2008 and you pointed out
that in some ways the fact that we
associate 2008 with perhaps the greatest
financial crisis we've had
in the post-cold war era has
overshadowed the creation of what you
call a supernova in 2007 the year before
could you tell us more about how those
two gate dates come together um
absolutely so um my chapter at she had
Moore's law and my book is called what
the hell happened in 2007 what the hell
happened in 2007 I know what you're
thinking what's this guy talking about
2007 such Annunaki was here well here's
what happened in 2007 the year was
kicked off actually On January 9th at
the Moscone Center in San Francisco when
a guy named Steve Jobs introduced the
first iPhone that iPhone is actually a
handheld computer with more compute
power in it than the Apollo space
mission and they tell me it doubles as a
phone and a camera that's how the Year
was kicked off in 2007 is actually late
2006 a company called Facebook opened
its platform to anyone with a registered
email address and in 2007 Facebook broke
out of high schools and universities and
went global in 2007 a company called
Twitter split off on its own independent
platform and went global in 2007 the
most important software you've never
heard of called VMware when public
VMware is what enables any operating
system to work on any computer it's the
foundation of cloud computing in 2007
the second-most important software
you've never heard of called a dupe
named after the founders son's toy
elephant was launched into the wild
Hadoop's what enables a million
computers to work together as if they're
one I think that's called big data
Hadoop 10 event those algorithms are
actually invented by Google they're
called GFS and MapReduce but as Doug
cutting the founder of a dupe explains
in the book a Google lives in the future
and sends us letters back home and what
Google did was leave a trail of
breadcrumbs for the open source
community to reverse-engineer their Big
Data algorithm and Hadoop was the free
public version and everyone in business
here is actually running it in the
background in 2007 the third most
important software you've never heard of
called github opened its doors
it's the largest repository of open
source software with 15 million users
and for the geeks among you will
appreciate the irony of
was bought last year by Microsoft in
2007 a company called Google launched
the little-known TV company was called
YouTube and in 2007 Google launched into
the wild its own operating system they
called it Android in 2007 IBM launched
the world's first cognitive computer
they called it Watson in 2007 a guy up
in Seattle named Jeff Bezos launched
world first ebook reader he called it
the Kindle in 2007 a company called
Netflix streamed its first video in 2007
late 2006 the internet crossed a billion
users seems to have been a tipping point
in 2007 an anonymous Japanese
cryptocurrency expert launched an essay
that launched a cryptocurrency
it was called Bitcoin in 2007 three
design students in San Francisco were
attending the design conference that
year and they notice all the hotel rooms
were sold out but one of them had three
spare air mattresses and they thought it
might be cool to see if they could rent
their air mattresses out to people who
couldn't get hotel rooms and it worked
out so well for them in 2007 they
started a company called air B&B yeah
that's where the title comes from there
three air mattresses now here's what
else happened in 2007 get the PowerPoint
up again so this is a graph of the cost
of sequencing a human genome you'll
notice it's a hundred million dollars in
2001 it falls to ten million in 2006 and
then you notice it goes over a cliff
like an EKG heading for a heart attack
in 2007 in 2007 solar energy took off as
did a process for extracting natural gas
from tight shale called fracking between
2006 and 2008 America's total natural
gas reserves increased by 35% a
staggering number for an 18-month period
and this is one of my favorite graphs
this is a picture of social networks so
that white line going down that's the
cost of generating a megabit of data and
you notice it collapses in 2007 the blue
line is the speed of generating that
data the two lines cross in 2008 close
enough for government work this is a
graph one of my favorites of cloud
compute
the first year we get statistics is 2008
which means the cloud was born around
2007 in 2007 Intel for the first time
went up silicon to extend Moore's law
introduced non silicon materials into
its microchips in 2005 Rana Michael Dell
retired the founder of Dell computers
and in 2007 he decided he better come
back to work
turns out friends 2007 I believe will be
understood in time as one of the single
greatest technological inflection points
since Gutenberg and we all completely
missed it and why did we miss it because
of 2008 yeah right when our physical
technologies took off like we're on a
moving sidewalk at an airport that
suddenly went from five to fifty miles
an hour right when that happened our
social technologies the learning reform
management reformed regulatory reform
you'd want to go with such an incredible
acceleration all froze because we
entered the deepest recession since 1929
and in that gap between what happened to
our physical technologies and what
happened to our social technologies many
many Trump and brexit voters were born
because many people got completely
dislocated Tom
it's a story purse of immense promise
and potentially very apocalyptic let's
take apart some of the elements please
one other thing that we had back in 2007
some would argue was privacy and the
chance of accountable government and
it's notable that in your account of how
the world has changed immeasurably it
may be irreversibly in the last 10 or 11
years you mentioned Microsoft you
mentioned Intel you've mentioned Google
in other words you've mentioned a huge
variety of very powerful corporations
none of which are accountable to
democratic processes in the ways that
governments are sure Anna Zubov has
written a very well guarded but recently
which has looked at what she calls
surveillance capitalism in other words
are we living these days in a consumer
paradise where essentially we have sold
our privacy and our capacity as citizens
to a bunch of corporations she may be
ever voted for her
a very good question and so the way I
kind of think about the Internet age
what to put in American baseball terms
like the first inning was fantastic Oh
something we got email and Siri in
Google and search but the second inning
has been a real bear okay
because second inning was when all these
things became apparent I did it you know
I had an interesting conversation which
I turned into a column Ron a couple
weeks ago with the people who run the
SAT program in America the College Board
and they run the SATs and the SAT choose
which drill down into some specialties
and David Coleman Stephanie Sanford they
concluded that there many things a high
school student needs to know when they
graduate high school but they decided
they're actually two things that every
high school student must know to codes
how to code a computer and the code of
the US Constitution and Mark Zuckerberg
is exhibit a of somebody who took the
first course and never took the second
course and well he did drop out of
Harvard oh yes I'm afraid he didn't get
to Khanna law and and the reason I say
this is that so a column III where
columns come from my head I don't really
know it's a kind of a chemical thing so
I'll come tie this point up by just
going around about for a second people
are often they're really they're really
trying to be nice and polite and so they
come up to you and say it like this week
we hear people say hey you work in a new
book and I say gee see I just wrote a
book about the three largest forces on
the planet reshaping the world and I
don't have three new ones this year okay
but as I thought about that it made me
sit back and think well what am i doing
you know what am i what am I seeing and
you really touched on it right with
actually what I realized what's going on
is all these forces are just going deep
so my wife is building a language museum
in Washington is called planet word it'd
be the world's first interactive word
language museum and we open in a year
and so my wife likes to come home she's
a real word person and at the end of the
year she always tells me what the word
of the year is because the online
dictionaries can now
that's a couple years ago was they
transgender people don't equal to eg one
called des hommes
last year interesting on Webster's
Merriman the word of the year was
justice most looked upward interesting
so I did a column saying I can tell you
what the word of the year is going to be
for 2019 close the contest now and I
think the word of the year is going to
be deep as in deep fake deep
surveillance deep insight deep mind deep
knowledge all these technologies are
going deeper on it but as your question
implied without a lot of the privacy
ethical regulatory considerations that
we need as these things go deep and it's
actually interesting if you watch the
Oscars because I do believe things are
in the zeitgeist what was the song of
the year it was Lady gaga the shallow
but you actually have to listen to the
song what's the song about we're leaving
the shallow now we're off in the deep
end and I really think that there's
something in the zeitgeist that people
sense that these technologies are going
deep and we have not put in place the
governing mechanisms or the ethical
mechanisms and you know one of the
reasons I called my books thank you for
being late is because it's actually in
celebration of everything old and slow I
really believe the faster the world gets
the more all the things you cannot
download but all the things you actually
have to upload the old-fashioned way
good parenting to good touch good child
good teacher to good student good pastor
to good flock good bureaucrat to good
citizen I think all the old stuff
matters more than ever and as we go deep
I think it's going to matter even more
but could I press you Tom on who that we
is right because I want to point out
that all of the companies you mentioned
in the society which it exists in
operate in our part of the world but you
could have mentioned by do you could
have mentioned consent you have
mentioned Alibaba in other words a huge
alternative universe really where
technology meets not liberal politics
but actually authoritarian politics and
people will look at China which of
course we're I'm talking about second
biggest economy in the world developing
five
artificial intelligence virtual reality
and using it for a whole variety of
purposes that we in the West might
consider in some ways extremely worrying
isn't there a danger first of all that
you know that's gonna head in a
direction that we have not been oh no
say over and seconded a version of that
could be our future as well the
surveillance capitalism yes turning us
to right so it's a very good question
and I would say this so I was in Jordan
a couple weeks ago
and one of the interesting things I had
seen there I hadn't seen before were
people actually tweeting against the
king and queen I mean saying you know
the Queen is this or that and signed Tom
Friedman seven one one seven Bradley
Boulevard Bethesda Maryland so well I
have never seen that before and so I
wrote a column about my time there and I
just threw into the middle of the column
a literally parenthetical graph and then
we get common center column and I notice
how many people commented and said I'm
not interested in Jordan that much but
that graph that graph was kind of
interesting so what did I say what
struck me there in Jordan I said I think
these social networks and cyber tools
are making efficient authoritarians even
more efficient I think they're making
soft authoritarians
or less efficient authoritarians more
vulnerable and frail and I think they're
making democracies uncomfortable so
that's a pretty strong statement
basically saying that yes you may
recognize some of that here
if we keep tweeting if we keep using the
social media that we have what's
happening whatever in the way we're
doing now yeah with the you know analog
version of politics that we have at the
moment that this is going to end badly
yeah I I I am net worried is the way I
put it right up side those of you follow
me know the New York Times tweets my
column I tweet my column out but I am
NOT on Twitter I've actually never
looked at Twitter I don't know what it
looks like I Kate if you ask me to
retreat something about your book I will
do it I've maybe done five tweets in my
life but I don't know how to do it my
secretary does it for me and that's
because anything said about me in 140
characters
anonymous person I'm actually not that
interested in and and if I miss the news
about the fire or the coup I'll get it
on CNN five minutes later but I'm I'm
really worried about a tendency I see in
journalism where everybody is looking
over their shoulder what is being said
about me my story I see this in the
Middle East people to cover
controversial stories in the Middle East
the israeli-palestinian conflict
well people there's an industry now
trying to game them you know the one
side is attacking you the other side is
attacking you and that gets in your head
and I just don't want that in my head
okay otherwise you start writing stories
for that person and so I in my world
everybody likes me you know because I'm
not on Twitter you know it's a I think
you're in that place no no I know
believe me I have no illusions about
that that's the most false statement I
make tonight but um what I'm saying is
you know the New York Times paid me to
to UM go out and report on the world and
call it as I see it
and if I start responding to every
single thing I'm not going to do that I
I happen to be good friends with one of
the coaches of an NBA team will go
nameless and um we were we were talking
a year ago and he told me now his
players come into the locker room at
halftime fire up their phones and see
what's said about them on Twitter in the
first half and I thought that is a sign
of the Apocalypse I mean that is like
where that goes is only a bad place and
so you have all these people going
around looking at their Twitter and
they're not looking at the world they're
not engaging like this you know like we
are I know who my friends are they're
not of thumb up or a thumb down you know
I mean and I really learned that you
know young people sometimes come to me
and I'm 65 now so I can say young people
everybody's young in my world and say I
want to do what you do what do you need
to know and I said well you know it's
really good to know how to type I
learned how to type really fast in fact
I went to night secretarial school in
London um 40 years ago to learn how to
type fast I can type really fast you
want to know some history some politics
some literature some Chinese history but
I think there's two things you need I
think to be a
journalist one is you have to like
people I like people so I really enjoy
hearing their their voices the crazy
things they say they do they aspire they
fear and if you can't hear the music you
can't play the music and you know
there's a few journalists out there who
really don't like people could I push a
bit on what you've just yeah there that
song because what it sounds to me your
fears is if you're saying and many
people would be very sympathetic with
this yes it's okay to know stuff it's
okay to actually write a column based on
the fact that you've been places seen
things done the homework and that gives
you more standing that gives you more
status than maybe someone on Twitter
which you don't read firing back to
their 940 characters when that person
doesn't really know anything about what
they're talking well the way I put it is
that you know my motto is that if you
don't go you don't know going doesn't
ensure knowing either you can go to a
place and get it completely wrong done
that - okay but I think it reduces the
odds that I get it wrong and that's all
I'm trying to do is increase the odds
that I get it right by going and
engaging but I wouldn't to make the
other I think the other thing you need
to be a I think an effective journalist
is that um you have to be a good
listener and it's for two reasons and
the second reason is more important than
the first are the first reason is
because what you learn when you listen
and the more important reason is what
you say when you listen this thing is a
sign of respect and it's amazing what
people will let you say to them or ask
of them if they think you respect them
and if they don't think you respect them
you can't tell them it's dark outside
and so listening is so important yes for
what you learn but much more for what
you say is that why if I had to find one
word to describe your style in columns
you probably the word conversational it
sounds very much as if you're putting
forward a style you know if it is as if
we're in a pub mmm my propensity that
doesn't after a pub could be a coffee
shop and kind of caught you and we're
just having a chat about something that
looks very natural but actually it
strikes me that it's not that easy to do
it doesn't literally come naturally well
you know the big criticism about me is
that
you know my stuff is too light too soft
and I should tell you that no readers
ever come up to me and said that Colin
was too much fun to read could make that
more complicated you know I mean and
he's never been an academic exactly
could you could you you know just make
that harder it more more impenetrable
and so I'm just trying to take complex
things and explain them for myself and
then if I can do that I can explain them
to other people because and at the front
of my book thank you for being late I
have a quote which is really my modest
from Marie Curie who said now is the
time to understand more so we may fear
less and that's the business I want to
be in I want to help people understand
more I may get it wrong but I'm that's
what I'm trying to do and we have so
many people now in in my business who
have a business model of making people
stupid making actually people confused
and stupid and angry and I have a great
contempt for that business model and so
I work at breaking things down so I can
understand it so other people can
understand it hopefully if I've got it
right and that they will fear it less
whether it's globalization or climate
change or all or whatever well let's
take one particular issue which i think
is permanent in the news it's an area
you know very well but frankly it's not
very well understood and that is the
state of the Middle East moment I know
that you've been in the Middle East
quite recently I've written recently
columns from Jordan as well as elsewhere
in the in the region let's talk about
Jordan itself remember you mentioned
this particular question about social
media but actually Jordan is one of
those places that sort of always slips
under the radar you know Iran or Egypt
or other places tend to grab the
headlines more and it's always struck me
that it's kind of an anchor state around
that part of the Middle East and an
anchor isn't always there it can be
pulled up and removed it's a very good
way to put it right you know it's a
buffer state buffer between Israel and
Iraq at one point on Israel and Saudi
Arabia Israel not I mean these are also
about Syria but um it's a place that
obviously has absorbed so many refugees
it's been a buffer that we have to
absorb now Syrian refugees either or
absorbed Iraqi refuse
it absorb Palestinians when they're
evicted from the Gulf after Gulf War one
and it's an important buffering state
it's not perfect it's got all kinds of
problems but boy we'd miss it if it were
gone you know I mean it would be there
would a lot be a lot of people grinding
directly up and how likely do you think
is that it might actually not be there
at some point in the near future
well I think what Jordan is worried
about very much right now is Jared
Kushner's peace plan they may not be the
only ones yes Ryan I'm worried about
Jared Kushner's peace plan um I would
say what they're worried about more
general Iran is trumps whole approach to
the israeli-palestinian conflict so you
know one of the things I've tried to
point out whether America's dealing with
Saudi Arabia or Israel or Egypt or
Jordan we played a role historically in
the region of being a reality enforcer
because all these leaders have cabinets
or are surrounded by people ruling
circles with moderates and centrist and
some really crazy people and and let's
take the Israeli cabinet and so so
Netanyahu or his predecessors always
needed to say when one of those crazy
stood up and said let's annex the Golan
Heights or let's annexed the West Bank
Netanyahu always needed to say I'd love
to do that crazy thing you want to do
I'm totally with you but the Americans
broke my arm okay I mean at the Emmy for
I debt the Americans would break my arm
now rather than playing that role we're
actually um encouraging extreme behavior
I mean you know when Trump moved the US
Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem I got
a call from from the White House where
they like never call but they called on
this one and said I just want you to
know we moved the embassy I'm from the
NSC staff we haven't moved the embassy
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem and I said oh
what did you get for it and there was a
silence on the line and I said to myself
oh no no no no don't don't tell me don't
tell me you gave it a wave for free okay
um we just did the same under Golan
Heights
so what do they get Stu Jordans one of
the jordanians well they gave away the
Jerusalem they gave away they go on
what's next the West Bank and if if
Trump sort of a sense to Israeli
annexation they're tested or real or
formal well he knows what's next
that's Jordans Palestine and that's so
they're terrified of this right now
and extremely extremely worried but the
other thing going on in Jordan you
really see is you know the air the first
Arab Spring really was about democracy
and voice and and young Arabs lost their
fear in the Arabs first Arab Spring this
Arab Spring if one is brewing now we see
in Algeria Sudan Gaza Jordan it's going
to be about youth unemployment and that
is now a pervasive problem in this part
of the world before automation has come
there so wait when automation comes and
so there's a real problem brewing there
around youth unemployment is there a
particular problem with youth
unemployment that is linked actually
with graduate training and higher
expectations and I'm thinking here the
fact that a very large number of people
who've got involved in extreme terror
groups in Egypt actually turn up to
being trained as engineers no they're
not sort of peasants out there in the
countryside these are people who have
learnt a lot they have high expectations
the expectations are not fulfilled you
only go in a particular direction yeah I
think that has to do with a broader
phenomena of humiliation I so I changed
my business card I brought wrong one
yeah I have a friend who works for BCG
Martin Revis and he changes a business
card every month um
and took puts out at the six things he's
thinking about so he got me thinking
about that and I decided that I had to I
had to have a business card that
actually described what I do so um my
business card now says Thomas L Friedman
New York Times humiliation dignity trust
leadership culture community ownership
and amplification columnist okay and
because those are actually all the
things I'm thinking about I'm a youth
each one yeah I wish they did but they
but they don't but for a long time I
used to call myself the New York Times
humiliation and dignity correspondent
because I realized I'd really
a lot of my career covering people
acting out on their humiliation and
questing for dignity whether it's China
after a century of humiliation Russia
after the Cold War Palestinians versus
Israelis Muslim used in Europe versus
the Christian majority there's a lot of
people walking around you know
humiliation is the single most powerful
human emotion I have found and the quest
for dignity and that gets back to my
listening point why listening is so
important and so you have now you have a
lot of young men in this part of the
world who have they've never held power
they've never held a job and they've
never held a girl's hand and that is a
really bad combination where do you see
that going you you've identified the
phenomenon you've been to those places
you see what's brewing up what do you
see coming next um you know I it's it's
really hard to know Rhonda let me let me
try to expand that question if I could
into the whole question of what happens
to all of these states okay so so I have
a chapter in the book which is called
control versus chaos basically it comes
out of a actually American TV show but
the argument I make is that you know the
world was governed by empires for
millennia until the late 19th and early
20th century and we broke up into all
these nation states particularly after
World War one and decolonization and
then World War two so much so that we
woke up in 1945 and we had a United
Nations with like 190 countries we'd
never had so many individual countries
before and the fifty years after World
War two were a great time to be a weak
little country if you were a weak little
country that was your era why first of
all there were two superpowers throwing
money at you foreign aids and you food
aid building your government house
educating your kids at Patrice Lumumba
University of Moscow Ohio State in
America you could be Syria and lose
three Wars to Israel and get your army
rebuild for free all three times it was
a great time for me a weak little state
number one number two populations or
moderate number three climate change was
moderate
really hadn't got kicked in number for
no one had a cell phone I couldn't see
Phoenix or Paris or London you know
and lastly China was not in the World
Trade Organization so everybody could be
in the low-wage textile business now my
argument is that in the early 21st
century around 2007 all of that flips
now no superpower wants to touch you
because all you win is a bill yes the
Russians are in Syria but they're not
rebuilding Syria they're just actually
exploiting Syria for their own you know
power projection number two populations
now have exploded so Nigeria will have
more people in America by 2050 Africa is
one point and four and 11 million
Africa's 1.2 billion people now it's
projected by the UN to have 2.4 billion
in 2050 climate change is out of control
I did a documentary last year on for
National Geographic following climate
refugees from Senegal Tunisia air up to
up to Europe and what you see in Senegal
in these villages in northern Senegal is
there no men in these villages between
the ages of 18 and 65 they've all left
because the land can't sustain them
anymore the small-scale agriculture and
and it's partly a climate change issue
because Senegal is already Senegal's at
two degrees rise average temperature
since the Industrial Revolution two
degrees rise average temperature where
have I heard that number oh that's what
the Paris climate agreement was designed
to prevent by 2100 Senegal is already
there they're going to four degrees and
lastly China is in the World Trade
Organization so nobody can be in the
textile business and so in fact I tell
the story that I was in Egypt for Tahrir
Square and I was there for three weeks
away from my wife and so I um I told the
story in the book I went I home I was at
the Cairo Airport I went into the
treasures of Egypt souvenir shop to buy
my my honey a little something to remind
her where her honey was and um let's see
what do they have here pyramids ashtrays
I'm not my honey doesn't smoke swings
bookends my honey has plenty of bookends
but um over here they had a stuffed
camel and they have stuffed CamLAN if
you squeezed its hump it honked and my
honey didn't have a honking honk camel
so um I picked it up and I turned it
over and what did it say on the bottom
made-in-china yeah you're the lowest
wage country in the eastern
Mediterranean and there's no country
half a world away can make your honking
humped camel cheaper than you can ship
it and sell it okay but so let me stress
Larry you know let me just finish it all
right I'm terrified by the camel but lay
low go on
so what's happening basically all these
weak little states they're now starting
to fracture and they're starting to
hemorrhage people in the hemisphere I
live in it's primarily Guatemala
Honduras and El Salvador who sent us a
hundred and eighty seven thousand
unaccompanied minors in the last four
years
that's just orphans and in this
hemisphere its sub-saharan Africa North
Africa and the Middle East and I think
the biggest geopolitical thing happening
in the world today Ron is the number of
people trying to get out of the world of
disorder into the world of order
changing the politics of the world of
order creating all these populist
nationalist backlashes
and I think the central geopolitical
challenge of our time is how do we
collaborate with these countries to
stabilize the world of disorder just as
we created a Marshall Plan to
destabilize Europe from the movement of
communism from east to west we need to
stabilize disorder moving from north to
south let me throw a scenario at you Tom
you perhaps respond to that point some
people say there is an outfit out there
that's doing the new Marshall Plan and
that's China's so-called
New Silk Road belt initiative and some
aspects of that are trying to deal with
the story that you just told so Ethiopia
you know very very interesting country
which shouldn't show you you've visited
I have wet but net next on the list for
any place even if not not been to to yet
we're in fact shoe factories are moving
from China to Ethiopia I mean there are
essentially Trump voters in southern
China or the equivalent of who are
saying the Africans are stealing all our
jobs yeah also China Japan South Korea
these places have demographics that are
getting old when old again another big
big year to come 2029 when China finally
gets older and faster and large parts
actually of the developed Asian world -
and with that belt in red initiative
with a new transport and security
network building up across the Eurasian
continent
looking east not west what are the
chances of that development maybe either
change
mitigating or just altering the dynamic
you're talking about people looking east
rather than west for that huge migration
that we're talking about I have a great
answer you tell me because I mean I you
know so anything in my view around that
that contributes to better governing
institutions and real economic activity
I think is a net plus the things I've
read about China's belt and road have
been ambiguous to me some looks
exploitative other looks you know like
it may have some of that potential but
to me this is a global project that this
is something the United States Russia
you we should actually be collaborating
on it so no way exactly exactly
oh yeah and try to I think try to shape
it in a in a productive way so I'm not
against it on principle at all I just
want to know it's gonna actually
stabilize these countries but I think
that I mean what are we doing in America
where she doing just the opposite I mean
Trump pulled out of the Paris climate
agreement at a time when climate change
is destabilizing his countries he's
banned the export of family planning
technology time the population is to
satisfy evangelicals and he just
announced he's withdrawing our aid from
El Salvador Guatemala Honduras until
they control their people better as if
they have ability to somehow do that and
just haven't heard from him you know all
the instruction so so what's scary to me
is we're actually making it worse not
actually thinking strategically about
this problem and the ultimate thing he
wants to is just put up a wall so I
think we've done really good don't
really well to get this far on the
conversation just ten yeah before we
start start the the view a and not
mention trumpeting at that point now
since you opened up that box Lucy let's
run with it a little bit because I just
think that the president United States
may come up just once or twice in the
questions we have let me ask a very
simple question do you think that there
will be a second Donald J Trump term in
office and what will it do to world
order if there is um I have no idea who
when I think is just too early to tell
I've spent so much on state of the
economy and which Democrat
some you know Japanese names on the
Democrat side no it really is right way
way too early you know and I think we I
think this will be though this will be
an unusual election I can't tell exactly
how but I think this is going to be an
election unlike any other unlike allow
so much is completely normal
well yeah exactly even crazier than the
last one um look forward to that yeah I
think the United States can survive four
years of Donald Trump and our
institutions will hold I do not think we
can survive eight years and what does
not surviving mean that I think he will
do irreparable damage to our system of
justice our institutions that I just
give you a small example we're now in
his third year president we have no
ambassador in Saudi Arabia
we have no ambassador in Egypt we have
no ambassador in Jordan we have no
ambassador in Iraq and we have no
ambassador in Turkey that's not a
mistake that's someone who just doesn't
think those are important and it's
actually true throughout the bureaucracy
and so what do you know demoralizing
that can be to a State Department and
now imagine that over eight years and
again who's going the kind of people you
get to be ambassadors also in this
administration doesn't exactly
strengthen those institutions so you
have a lot of young people to say I know
I'm gonna go to Oxford I'm gonna study
with Ron I'd like to be in China but hey
I don't want going the State Department
now nobody cares about it at all and
that's just one example so you know
these institutions we have these are
crown jewels I've heard they're two
views on the Trump administration as an
international actor one is the view that
essentially the administration is
dismantling the international order as
we've known it since 1945 the other is
that yeah he tweets a lot there's lot of
rhetoric but when you look at the core
policies actually not such a big change
with which side you sound like you'd
fall more on the former yeah I see it's
partly the the part of the world it
depends on which part of the world
you're talking about
I mean like I'm the question of China
one of my sort of best thinkers in China
likes to say that Donald Trump is not
the American president Americans deserve
but he is the American president China
deserved okay and you know I think I
think China got rich around over the
last thirty years with three things
three main strategies hard work
education in smart investments in
infrastructure delayed gratification
national unity pulling together
number one basket second basket stealing
intellectual property forced transfer of
Technology non reciprocal trade
arrangements and consistent violation of
WTO rules third basket the American
Pacific Fleet the American Pacific Fleet
has been very important for China's
growth because it allowed everyone on
the periphery of China to feel we can be
economically dominated by China but we
won't be physically militarily dominated
and but that second basket was China got
rich metaphorically using that second
basket and the first on exaggerated but
t-shirts tennis shoes solar panels if we
allowed them to use the same strategy on
aerospace biomaterials supercomputing
we'd be making a huge mistake I think
and and I think therefore Trump you know
some things are true even if Donald
Trump believes them and I'm a big big
believer tommix noticed Donald Trump
because you may not have heard but we
are very shortly about to do great trade
deals with China once we liberate
ourselves from of Europe and if I man
got a quote from the New York Times this
morning where with objectivity calm and
a certain amount of restraint your
column today is headlined the United
Kingdom has gone mad you've obviously
are not impressed by brexit do you think
the question I have for you is do you
think actually this is just a little
local difficulty you know it's important
to us but the further you go away from
Northwest year at the lesson matters or
is this something that has greatest
significance I think there's enormous
significance let me put it in in a
broader historical context and then I'll
drill down after the Second World War I
think the world that we were lucky we
were blessed by having some great
statesmen and women but in those days
more men than women who built the
institutions that governed the post-cold
war world post-world war ii world and it
was the eventually the Common Market it
was the World Bank who is the IMF was
the United Nations and and a certain set
of norms and values as well about non
seizure of territory and the like we
were very lucky that the Statesman who
came together to build that world I
think in 1989 we reached another real
critical junction with the collapse of
communism and we were again I was lucky
enough to be covering Secretary of State
James Baker then but to have a front row
seat to another group of I think very
talented and high-minded States men and
women George HW Bush Margaret Thatcher
Jim Baker Brent Scowcroft Helmut Kohl
Francois Mitterrand and most of all
Mikhail Gorbachev and those people
really I think designed the transition
and shape the transition of the of the
post 1989 where we were really lucky
2007 is another fulcrum point and I
think our luck ran out I don't think we
have the kind of leaders with either the
vision or more importantly that
selflessness of of those people I don't
want to exaggerate it but the
willingness to do the right thing I
think we have a real shortage of those
leaders at another fulcrum point in
history and that makes me really nervous
if we don't have those leaders and clear
at least many millions of people who
voted for them might think that we do
why don't we so um that's a problem I
just don't know it's out of our skill
set I do blame social media but for some
of it I think it's just harder to be a
leader today because you are constantly
uh you've got so much chirping in your
ear all the time and I think that's part
of it that's not the whole story by any
means but I think that's part of the
story it's part of it also that some
have argued that one generate two
generations ago most leaders had gone
through the Second World War as leaders
or that fought and the generation after
that had fought the Cold War and
understood the nuclear stakes and the
generation that came of age after 1990
didn't exactly either of those things
and I think that that's very true I I
don't think I mean the whole you know
Bill Clinton Monica Lewinsky thing that
you know that was just part of the sort
of frivolousness of that of that era but
what what troubles me I
Rex it's not my business per se this is
the choices for the British people what
troubles me is how how poorly the choice
was prepared and presented I would have
expected a hundred different competing
studies on what would be the
implications of brexit I'm not sure the
government did even one if they did one
I didn't you know it wasn't widely
publicized you know and what bothers me
I'll be very blunt
you know it's playing with big systems
you don't play the EU is a big system
you can be for der against it I totally
respect that but don't play with it
don't say I'm going to be for brexit
because I know it's gonna fail and then
when it fails I'll be able to position
myself as the guy who was against it and
that will allow me to take over the you
know the Conservative Party and my name
is Boris Johnson and you know you know
and it is what you really think yeah and
so I call that playing with big systems
and then what happens you know they
never thought the dog would catch the
car and the dog caught the car and now
it's sitting on the hood and it's
barking at you
you know and you're playing with big
systems you can be against it you can be
for it but you have to be serious about
it and you're being serious about it is
answering several questions what world
am i living in what are the biggest
trends in this world and how do i align
my country to get the most out of these
trends and cushion the worst and is the
EU helpful in that or not well I think
one world you're living in is a world of
rapidly accelerating change and in a
world of rapid change the most open
system wins because you get the signals
first you respond fastest and you
attract the most high IQ risk takers
because they want to work in open
systems you're living in a world where
all the problems are global and all the
solutions have to be global and if you
want to have a say in those solutions
and your name is not Russia China
America or India you better be part of a
larger coalition you know Tom we could
go on for ages but we've got to open up
to the audio because there are so many
other views I should want one last thing
before we usually open up and I'm sure
they'll be views on Trump for exit in
both directions and an audience that's
large so we'll see what we what we hear
you've told us at least three big
overarching stories that we need to be
aware of but you also travel the world
you see a lot of stuff the rest of us
don't get to see if there's one small
quirky unexpected thing that you've seen
somewhere in the world recently that
you'd like us to know about what might
that be it's a good question and really
um is something I ended my book on right
yeah um and and it's really been guiding
my journalism a lot lately
and that is the fact that you know the
cliche about America is that were a
country divided between two coasts to
coast set our liberalizing pluralizing
globalizing and diversifying and then
there's flyover America where everyone's
high in opioids voted for Trump and
waiting for 1950 to come back okay that
that's sort of that that's the cliche
you know I mean in fact America is a
checkerboard of towns and communities
some of which are actually rising from
the bottom up amazingly and others that
are collapsing from the bottom down
truly collapsing into opioid abuse
suicide unemployment and divorce and
what I've been trying to focus on and
understand since I wrote my book is what
distinguishes one from the other and so
I'll tell you the backstory of the
biggest column literally the longest
column I've written in the last year I
got a call from my lecture agent um last
you know winter and he said you got a
lecture request to speak in Lancaster
Pennsylvania town in in eastern
Pennsylvania for a group called the
hourglass foundation do a book talk so I
agreed to do it a week before I go out
there my agent calls and says I'm I
forgot to tell you you have to do a
90-minute reception with the group
before the talk I said to him Carlton
you're killing me ninety minutes before
I talk I'll be dead not part of the deal
so I go there and I braced myself for
this reception in Lancaster and I go
into the room and suddenly it's hi I'm
from the Lancaster Health coalition I'm
from Lancaster Youth Coalition
I'm from the last canter LED abatement
coalition I'm from Lancaster housing
coalition I'm from Lancaster
anti-poverty coalition I suddenly
realized I'm in an amazing place before
the evening is done I've already
arranged to come back and interview
everybody in the town's leadership and
last June I wrote a piece on Lancaster
Pennsylvania Lancaster Pennsylvania was
a dying town in the 1990s no one would
go downtown and in 2018 Lancaster
Pennsylvania was named by Forbes
magazine one of the ten coolest cities
in America and I went back and told the
story of how this got turned around and
the basic story is that the towns the
hourglass foundation was called the
hourglass Foundation because they
thought the hour was late and what
happened was the town's leaders came
together and they built what I call a
complex adaptive coalition where the
business community partnered with the
philanthropic community partner with the
education community partnered with the a
social entrepreneurial community partner
with city government they created a a
complex adaptive coalition they meet
every Friday morning
around the kitchen table and art man's
house and they plotted the rebuilding of
their town and over a twenty year period
so I call this a complex adaptive
coalition their philosophy is what works
you check your politics at the door we
only do what works here and I told the
story about how the big breakthrough was
when they got a convention center they
got the budget for a convention center a
new hotel in the heart of the town and
the budget process went through I'll end
here when the local Republican
congressman teamed up with the
Democratic mayor and got the bond issue
through got the government to back the
bond issue and wouldn't you know run in
the next election the Democratic mayor
forgot to endorse the Democrat running
against the Republican Congress made
good so if you want to be an optimist
about America today stand on your head
my country looks so much better from the
bottom up than from the top down and
that is because these coalition's are
coming together actually all over the
country we have communities that are
falling apart do not get me wrong but
the country is actually a checkerboard
and what distinguishes the community
satirising
from those that are falling is a whole
new leadership category it's something
my teacher Getty Greenstein calls
leaders without authority these are
people in the community who step forward
and just say not going to happen here an
optimistic note is a great place at
which to switch the direction of our
conversation I say that's right I can
usually ruin any dinner party and um and
I do weddings and bar mitzvahs okay so
it's some but I'll do this event indeed
well we're very glad to have that
positive note of which to turn out to
our huge audience here today at the
Emmanuel centre we have a three over
there could be give that to yep thank
you so much for a wonderful talk to you
um when it comes to globalization stand
up sorry to say everyone could you stand
up we speak so you can be a same
constellation that big big issue that's
erupted at particularly ever since 2016
now is cybersecurity ya know we're bout
to move into the Internet of Things
we're about to move into the driverless
cars about to move into close with chips
in them and so far you know we have
several terrible products on the market
in our security do you see any new trend
in cybersecurity that's coming out
particular relation to the events of
2016 or is it still coming under the
radar G finger so this will WAIS bad
it's a really good question and
important question I'm not an expert on
cybersecurity but um I would say the
challenge is about actually explode and
today is a memorable day because our
biggest telecom company called Verizon
today launched its 5g network now 5g
people don't realize how important this
is I mean we had a steam engine
we had electrification we had
digitization and we're not gonna have 5g
and it is that of that scale of change a
a video a movie a Hollywood film that
took you eight minutes to download will
now take you eight seconds with zero
latency as this gets deployed and it
will truly course through the whole
economy and the cyber implications of
that will be enormous and so we've got
this arms race going on all the time
between bad guys and the good guys and I
wish I could tell you the good guys have
won the race is over but they haven't
and bad guys are always early adopters
so because they who are the bad guys in
this scenario I mean bad guys are
criminals there are foreign countries
there there are all kinds of people so I
wish I I wish I could tell you we're on
top of this I can't I think it's going
to be something we're gonna have to live
with for a long long time so we have
number four everything yes thank you
that was really interesting
first she just want to add that Twitter
as 280 characters that don't affair
changes it seems to me that I'm gonna
marry a couple of please your interests
here my question it seems to me that
looking at the israeli-palestinian
conflict looking at the state of inter
governmental relations with Israel and
Palestinians is somewhat of a red
herring yeah the problem really lies at
their inter-communal level there was not
good relations between Israelis and
Palestinians ordinary Israelis and
Palestinians while social media has a
deleterious impact on the state of
political discourse across the world
I do just wonder if the younger
generation
with a better more refined social media
Atika could actually lead to improve
discourse between young Israelis and
Palestinians which could actually
potentially lead to some sorts of
solution in the future so I just kind of
wanted to hear your thoughts on that
that's a very thoughtful question I I
tend not to invest technology with that
kind of power my own experience is that
um that what actually creates that
breakthrough you're talking about is not
technology but actually politics in this
sense i I've always believed that
Israelis will never really be truly at
home unless Palestinians can take you
know are at home and Palestinians will
never be truly at home and able to take
their shoes off unless Israelis are and
the reason that becomes important is
because it's only then that the Israeli
says to the Palestinian once they're
both secure in their own space what were
you trying to tell me about humiliation
you know I mean that's when they hear
and that's when the the Palestinian says
the Israeli what were you trying to tell
me about the Holocaust you were trying
to remember you you're trying to tell me
something yeah it's only when people are
secure in their own space and then you
know what they don't need Twitter they
don't need Facebook you know just need
an old telephone or to meet you know for
coffee but I think that the politics has
to get right first lady over here
excellent under three hi I'm fantastic
thank you thank you and you spoke about
the fact that you didn't want people to
invade your space and show you what you
think the greatest thing that's hitting
the world at the moment is teenage
mental health yeah and how it effects
and I know there's a huge campaign with
the Royals there's a huge campaign to
protect teenagers yes and it's easy for
you to switch off and say you're not
going to listen I would say that that's
one of the hugest impacts on Future
Leaders is that they're listening too
much and they care too much yeah and
that's why our rates of suicide
especially young men is going up people
list the teenagers are listening too
much so that's why they don't create
good leaders because they're worried
about what people think yeah I think
that's a it's a I don't have any ad just
to add to your point and there's a
another dimension of it which I I got
into in in my book I I have a
interesting interview with our Surgeon
General our leading
government doctor vivec more tea and I
was interviewing when I was writing the
book and I said to him one day of avec
what's the most prevalent disease in
America is it heart disease cancer or
diabetes
he said it's none of those it's
isolation I said wait a minute we live
in the most connected age in history and
you're telling me I so yeah that
basically depression related isolation
you saw that with the guy is terrible
person who shot up the mosque in New
Zealand you know all these guys have
pretty much the same profile they're
kind of marinating at home and all these
websites alone that they don't have
strong relationships with people and and
that's why I just really so worried but
you know you have all these teenagers
you see their friends on Instagram I was
not invited to that party I must be ugly
I must be unpopular you know and so I'm
not I talked the talk of Technology but
I actually don't walk the walk I'm a
late adopter of a lot of things I I get
it I have a I'm a privilege for I have a
column in The New York Times yeah I mean
so I understand that but at the same
time you know my wife edits all my
columns literally virtually every column
except May one from the Arctic you know
but my wife has edited and so I've also
got someone I really trust who would
look out you know for might but also is
not the least bit afraid to telling me
that is the worst column you've ever
written and you need to start over okay
and so but we all kind of need that kind
of person in our lives today and
unfortunately I feel there's so many
young people that are getting marinated
in some really dangerous stuff number
one has been extremely patient so right
at the back of the head hello it's been
very insightful think very much thank
you
I wanted to ask on your views on the
us-mexico relations and more broadly
speaking US Latin America relations yeah
short on longer terms I think a very
good question so yeah I think we are so
lucky America we have this North
American platform of we have this
neighbor to the south that's
democratizing shares a lot of our value
our cultures integrated with our economy
we have a neighbor to the north the same
way
the last people in the world I would
want to antagonize is Mexico I mean
we're we're so lucky to have this stable
neighbor and I really fear that Donald
Trump has hit on a a campaign tool which
is making people frightened or either
culturally flight frightened or
physically frightened by using Mexico in
particular and Latin Americans in
general as his foil and we're so lucky
Mexico has been amazingly patient you
know I mean the only real blowback was
when former President Vicente Fox said
we're not going to pay for your [ __ ]
wall
you know you know so I asked of my
Mexican friends is just wait this out
hopefully it's about 18 more months you
know and hopefully we'll get things back
to normal
but thanks for your question that we
have number two over that thank you very
much very interesting opinions oh please
yeah thank you very much I want to hear
your opinion about Turkey and
considering the most recent local
elections um just for anyone here who
hasn't been following Turkey to some
people surprise the opposition did
extremely well in Ankara Istanbul and
other cities
pushing back against early on in the
elections of the last few days thank you
I just think this is fantastic
what happened because the thing I love
about being a reporter is that people
always surprise you and just when one of
these dictators thinks they've got it
all wired I got all the courts I got all
the TV I got all the newspapers I got
all the business along come the people
and they actually tell them what they
think and um now I don't want to
exaggerate it was the big cities but
they're very important and for them to
triumph over a deck that was so stacked
against them
it gives me actually hope as an American
Trump seriously it gives me hope for
Russians avizo V Putin because we kind
of got a whole class of leaders around
the world today err Diwan Sisi MBs Putin
they've all kind of stacked the deck in
a way and and there's this feeling like
there's nothing we can do and God bless
the people of Turkey I think they sent a
very important message that had the
whole brexit debate not been going on
here I think it'd have been a huge story
around the world but just briefly on
that Tom the difference between Ariane
and MBS and say what is that he was
elected in elections which were you know
a popular man we and many of us here
liberals do not like the fact he was
elected but he was in a different
category from pure dictators right well
you know what I've learned over the
years Ron it I think you you'll agree
with me on China
I found that dictators are the most
intense Polar's in the world thank you
in Chinese
dictators because they're always
insecure and and so you know there's a
there's a there's a song by Neon Trees
as a rock group that um I really like
because it has a line in it that I've
always found to be true in my journalism
which is that everybody talks you think
they're not talking to each other in
Turkey in China no they actually know
who's stealing who's um you know who's
corrupt who's being abusive and you'll
never know when it's gonna when it's
gonna come out and so I don't think any
leader today no matter how repressive he
is or she is whatever kid cannot is
sitting comfortably on their throne
everybody talks we have number three
over here mr. Friedman if you were
president Trump what car would you play
in order to unlock the political
stalemate currently happening in
Venezuela that is a really good question
a question number four up there please
somebody had a fall there it is it no I
I wish I had I've only been to Venezuela
once I wish I had a more intelligent
answer for you but here's what I think
we're doing and not doing too badly but
you tell me and it gets to that line on
my business card which is um
amplification so I've learned the hard
way that how much I don't know about
countries but there's one thing I think
I can still see and that is when someone
is doing the right thing in a country
that we care about try to amplify it and
so I think that's what we're trying to
do with the opposition I think we're not
gonna invade Venezuela that we shouldn't
be invading Venezuela I think we're
trying to be very careful about what we
do but there's clearly a large number of
Venezuelans that want to change in the
political system but there's also very
rooted you know a group that's holding
on and I think in this kind of situation
the smartest thing for us to do is do
everything we can to amplify the
democratic forces ultimately femen's
Whelan's have to sort this out I hope
they do it peacefully but I'm really
into amplification now and I kind of
think that's what we're doing and and it
seems to be heading tilted more in the
right direction in the wrong direction
I hope okay thank you thank you for that
we have before over here Dom I redo it
call them judiciously for many many
years and I read all your books
bless your heart
he's brought about a sign as well my
question is with Bob Mueller's
investigation complete and out and
apparently Trump escaping does it
enhance his chances for a second term
that's a it's a very important question
um so I personally I never really wrote
much about collusion I I I just never
saw a smoking gun and what was reported
in the press I never thought Trump was
organized enough to collude okay so uh
but I would urge you to to hold that
question
remember the reports almost 400 pages
can you imagine what's in there all you
know is the conclusion which was that a
fair-minded you know a special
investigator a special counsel said I
got all this evidence not that he's
innocent effective clear said this does
not exonerate him
but I don't think in a court of law I
can prove it to indict the president
so right now Donald Trump's having a
really good time using that you know
part of the Moller report to to drive
home as much as he can he's trying to do
this deliberately
I've been exonerated exonerate
exonerated but today the US Congress the
Democrats are subpoenaed the full
document said we don't want a redacted
version and I promise you it will come
out and when it does it will not be a
good day for Donald Trump but that said
I'm a big believer I do not want Donald
Trump impeached unless there truly are
provable high crimes and misdemeanors I
think it is vitally important for
America that we vote him out the way he
was voted in that he see and we see that
we could render a judgment on this man
and that the world see that America came
back to its senses and can render a
judgment on this and I do not want him
impeached I want him voted out the way
he was voted in
[Applause]
[Music]
number two yes of you it's going back to
the Middle East and really with
reference to Jordan which as you'd
mentioned has all these refugees from so
many different countries
Jordan has no natural resources and it
has to be boosted by UN and anybody else
in America who so on why is it what can
we do to make the Middle East oil States
pay for their their own and look after
that yeah why does it have to fall on
Joe Jordan alone yeah it's a very good
question you know one good thing that
both Obama and Trump have done is that
they they massively increased our aid do
you know we're not giving close to two
billion dollars a year to Jordan which
is which is not insignificant amount of
money Jordans core problem actually all
happened as a result of the Arab Spring
a byproduct of it when the Arab Spring
happened in Egypt anti regime forces in
the Sinai
cut the gas pipeline from Egypt to
Jordan and Jordan had really shifted his
whole energy system over to natural gas
much cheaper much more sustainable when
the pipeline was broken they had to
start re-imported diesel fuel and it may
also been cold they had to redo their
whole energy system and to put them 7.5
billion dollars in debt and that's what
the IMF now has been trying to help them
then work out you know it'd be nice
obviously if any of the Gulf states just
wrote them a check and made that debt go
away and by all rights they they should
be but it's not likely to happen and I
think that raising that question that's
one of the things we should be doing
again if there would be a great job for
the American president to be doing or
for the European Union to really make an
issue of it because Jordan is exactly it
is absorbing and absorbing all these
refugees helping keep the region stable
it's doing a great service I mean it's
quite remarkable they have two shifts
school today you know for Syrian
refugees and other refugees you know to
be able to go to school as well I mean I
think they're doing a very noble thing
I'm glad you draw attention to it I try
to draw attention to it I think we can't
do that enough so thank you if they
don't write a check maybe the Chinese
will who knows that would be let's let's
take number three in anticipation of
tonight I thought I'd do a bit of
research on yourself so I start about
Wikipedia in the first paragraph it
seems to say that your staunch supporter
of the Iraq war sabzi and I sort of
clicked a few hyperlinks and could see a
2003 column from you but you did say
that it had to be so fancy Saddam and
the child sort of progressive and
democratic impacts in the region yeah my
question is basically in hindsight do
you think there's any way that an armed
invasion of Iraq could have had let's
positive impacts on the region and the
world - it's an important question and
obviously one I've been asked before as
you said I kind of had my own reasons
for supporting the war which were not
about WMD at all
I believed that unless we could partner
with people in the in the Middle East to
bring more consensual government and
pluralism they're both political
pluralism religious pluralism and gender
pluralism that that part of the world
was going to go off a cliff and so I was
never into the WMD part of the war my
view was if you're going to go to war
let's do it for the right reasons and
that's really how I came into it the
question is could it ever have worked I
don't know but we I would argue that we
never gave it a try because when we went
in and immediately took apart the Iraqi
army and de-baathification and told them
you're not gonna be part of the future
of this country
and that led to the backlash and whatnot
and under the disaster that land was
exacerbated by the Isis thing I think
the interesting question today though
about Iraq and
I'm glad you bring it up is that um
you're one of the things about the Iraq
war we'll never know and that's the
counterfactual what if Saddam had stayed
and again for me if Saddam its data I
don't think there had been some nuclear
thing I think Iraq could look a lot like
Syria today
now I'd lock the rocks been through its
own hell own kind of hell since the war
but if you look at Iraq today it said
multiple elections got huge corruption
problems it's got still huge internal
refugee problems but it's kind of
stumbling its way forward you know to
some kind of consensual power-sharing
you don't have what's going on in Syria
going on there today and the question
for me going forward is is this
i I will never feel anything but regret
for the price that was paid in Iraq by
Iraqis by Brits by Americans but you can
you can overpay for diamonds and you can
overpay for cut-glass and my focus since
the war has been always to try to
nurture this thing in a way that will
over paid for something that actually
created some kind of decency there we
have it in Kurdistan I hope we get it in
the rest of Iraq so I have nothing but
regret for how that played out but I
still believe and would not back away
from my belief that unless we could find
a way to partner with people there to
bring more consensual government
pluralism to that part of the world
you're gonna get one Syria and Libya
after another I'm because squeeze did
one very last quick question and quick
answer before we have to wrap up number
one over there no pressure that was the
last question thank you
in the beginning you talked about three
factors that are reshaping the world
mores lobbying one but then you said
there are five areas that you see being
influenced Epic's being one can you just
expand on that yeah I'm actually gonna
take a few minutes on that one because
after your very important um so my
chapter on ethics is called is God in
cyberspace and it's actually the best
question I ever got on book tour it was
selling a book called Lexus and the
olive tree and I was in Portland Oregon
came to question time just like this and
a young man stood up in the balcony said
mr. Friedman I have a question is God in
cyberspace and I said I have no idea and
I felt like an idiot so I came home and
I called my spiritual teacher he's a
rabbi I got to know when I was in our
times corresponding in Jerusalem his
name three marks a brilliant tel Mutis
and now lives in Amsterdam married to a
Dutch priest interesting character I
called I called svey in Amsterdam and I
said see I got a question I've never had
before He is God in cyberspace what
should I have said he said well Tom in
our faith tradition we have two concepts
of the Almighty one is a biblical
concept that the Almighty is Almighty he
smites evil and rewards good and if
that's your view of God he sure isn't in
cyberspace which is full of pornography
gambling cheating lying prevarication
people smearing one another on Twitter
and now we know fake news okay but
unfortunately he said we have a post
biblical view of God and the post
biblical view of God says God manifests
himself by how we behave so if we want
God to be in cyberspace we have to bring
him there by how we behave there only we
can bring God into cyberspace really
liked his answer I put it into the 20 mm
paperback edition of Lexus olivetree
where none of you saw it and it's sat
there for 16 years I sat down to write
this new book and I found myself
retelling that story spontaneously and
one day I set myself down and said why
are you retelling that story and the
answer became immediately clear to me it
was for two reasons and one just
happened I think in the last couple of
years we at least in the developed world
we began living 51 percent of our lives
in cyberspace that's where you go now to
find a date find a spouse buy a book
write a book sell a book buy a house
black car get a mortgage do your
brokerage get your news make your news
send your pictures we're now living 51%
of our lives in cyberspace and what's my
definition of sybers
it's a realm where we're all connected
and no one's in charge we're all
connected and no one's in charges no
courts in cyberspace no police no
firemen no 1-800 please stop Putin from
hacking my election but that's where
we're living 51 percent of our lives in
other words we're living 51 percent of
our lives in a realm that is
fundamentally god free and at the same
time because of my accelerations we're
now standing at a moral intersection we
have never stood at before as a species
in 1945 we entered a world where one
country could kill all of us post
Hiroshima I think we're entering a world
where one person can kill all of us and
at the same time where all of us could
actually fix everything these
accelerated powers are creating a world
where one of us could kill all of us and
all of us if we put our mind to it we
now have the tools to feed house clothe
and educate every person on the planet
we have never been to this intersection
before what is this intersection we have
never been more godlike as a species
than we are today well put those two
together you've never lived more of your
life in a realm that's Godfrey and we
have never been more godlike what does
that mean it means what every single
person thinks feels and believes today
really matters it means everyone needs
to be in the grip of sustainable values
and at a minimum the Golden Rule do unto
others as you wish them to do unto you
because you now live in a world where
more people can do unto you farther
faster deeper cheaper than ever before
and you can do unto others farther
everyone needs to be in the grip of the
golden rule in every faith and culture
has their version of it I know what
you're thinking I gave this part of my
talk as the commencement address a few
years ago at Olin College of Engineering
and I told the parents at graduation I
know what you're thinking
you pay 200 grand
so your kid could get an engineering
degree and who do they bring in as the
commencement speaker but a knucklehead
promoting the golden rule is there
anything more naive and what I told them
is what I would tell you naivete is the
new realism because I'll tell you what's
really naive thinking we're going to be
okay in a world that gets this
interdependent we're men women machines
get this super empowered if everyone is
not in the grip of sustainable values
where do people learn the Golden Rule
two places strong families and healthy
communities I'm not an expert on strong
families I hope I built one would never
presume to lecture anyone on that but I
am an expert on healthy communities
because I grew up in one a little town
outside of Minneapolis called st. Louis
Park and that's why my book ends in the
little town where I grew up and learned
these values and that's why I said at
the beginning what I'd repeat now that
the faster the world gets all the old
stuff matters more than ever all the
stuff you cannot download but have to
upload the old-fashioned way good
parenting to good child good pastured a
good flock but teacher to good student
it's all the stuff you can't download
that matters more than ever thank you
[Applause]
you